[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vois que monsieur a besoin d'un grand
amour quelle chance il a Monsieur car
c'est l'article du jour il le trouvera
là-bas avec un prix de réclame à côté de
la poudre à récurer les ES et si par
chance monsieur a fait son plein
d'illusion il ne laissera pas passer
notre promotion de baril de bonheur et
pour un prix dérisoir il aura en cadeau
un échantillon d'espoir alors
Monsieur dites-moi que la vie c'est
bien dans ce grand
magasin non j'ai rien vu de
jolie et j'ai rien mis dans mon cadis
et si monsieur veut bien passer cet
après-midi il perdra pas son temps ça SZ
jurer promis puisque voici venir
l'animateur vedette qui va nous
réapprendre le sens de la fête je vois
qu'il y a de la place dans l'existence
de Monsieur pour mettre un double pack
d'événement heureux gardez bien les
capsule pour la loterie générale dont le
premier prix est une réussite sociale
alors
monsieur dites-moi que la vie c'est
bien dans mon grand
magasin j'ai rien vu de
jolie et j'ai rien mis dans mon
cadis moi j'étais pas très chaud pour
faire tous ces achats mais j'aimais la
vendeuse et lui confiais tout bas
mademoiselle je vous aime c'est nouveau
mais c'est bon elle m'a dit les coups de
foudre ça c'est pas mon rayon mais
monsieur dites-moi que la vie c'est bien
mais dans ce grand magasin il avait
quelle de
jolie mais mon Cadie lui a rien
[Musique]
dit j'ai laissé la vendeuse à son
bonheur de papier en gardant mon cœur
vide qui était même pas consigné et tout
seul dans ma peau qui était trop grande
pour moi j'ai fui comme un voleur des
choses qui existaient pas même dites
pas dites pas que la vie n'est
rien que ce grand
magasin dites-moi qu'elle est jolie la
vie
et mettez-la dans mon
[Musique]
cadis